بخطه ذكيه ومحكمه استغرق الاعداد لها ثلاث
سنوات كامله تمكن مع افراد عصابته من سرقه
20 مليون دولار من اكبر مصرف في بيونس
ايريس ورغمه انهم لم يتركوا اي اثر خلفهم
الا ان عمليه القبض عليهم لم تكن متوقعه
الاسم عصابه مشروع دوناتيلو التهمه اقتحام
ونهب مصرف المكان يونس ايريس الارجنتين
الحكم السجن 15 عاما
عام 2003 كان هناك مزارع يدعى اراوجو اراد
الانتقال للعيش في المدينه ليستقر به
الحال في بيت المجاور لاكبر بنوك العاصمه
الارجنتينيه بيونس ايرس وبسبب سوء الاحوال
الاقتصاديه التي كان يمر بها بدا يخطط
لتنفيذ مشروع دوناتيلو وهو الاسم الذي
اطلقه على خطته في نهب البنك المجاور
لمنزله
بذكائه الشديد استطاع اراجو ان يقنع جاره
ميكانيكي الدراجات الناريه سباستيان
غارسيا بالانضمام اليه بصفته مهندسا مهنيا
ثم زاد الفريق اكثر فاكثر ليصل عدد افراد
العصابه الى ثمانيه الخطه بدات عندما
اكتشف وجود انفاق الصرف الصحي اسفل منزله
وكانت كبيره باستطاعه الانسان ان يتحرك
داخلها بكل اريحيه
انفاق الصرف الصحي لم تكن تصل الى اسفل
البنك مباشره فكان يتعين على العصابه حفر
نفق للوصول الى النقطه المطلوبه وبعد
ثلاثه سنوات من العمل الشاق دقت ساعه
الصفر
في الثالثه عشر من يناير عام 2006 اقتحم
بعض افراد العصابه الباب الاماميه للمصرف
حاملين اسلحه بلاستيكيه واحتجزوا بعض
الرهائن اما باقي افراد العصابه فشقوا
طريقهم الى خزنه المصرف عبر النفق
واستولوا على ملايين الدولارات وكميات من
الذهب ثم لذا الجميع بالفرار بعد زرع
قنبله بلاستيكيه في طريق الشرطه لتعطيل
حركتها
زعيم العصابه كان بارعا في تضليل الشرطه
نثر في الموقع مئات من بصيلات الشعر
لاشخاص اخرين والقى بعض الكروت البنكيه في
اماكن متفرقه من العاصمه لكن كما يقال لا
توجد جريمه كامله
وهو احد افراد العصابه كان افشى تفاصيل
العمليه كامله لزوجته ظنا منه انها موضع
ثقه وعندما جاء اليوم الذي قرر فيه بيتتو
خيانه زوجته بات ليلته التاليه خلف
القضبان بعد باقي افراد العصابه بعد ان
وجد زوجته بهم جميعا انتقاما من بيتو وفي
عام 2010 قدمت العصابه الى المحكمه حكم
على بيت بالسجن 15 عاما وحكم على اراجو
وبقيه الفريق ب 14 عاما خلف القضبان خطه
محكمه اعجزت الشرطه والمحققين وثلاث سنوات
من التخطيط والتنفيذ هدمتها خلال لحظات
وشايه امراه ارادت الانتقام من زوجها
الخائن
[تصفيق]